We will practice going
between reference frames
to look at relative
velocities in one dimension.
Let's say that an observer
is standing on the sidewalk
and that observer
sees a car drive
past to the right
at a speed of v car.
The observer also
sees a bike that's
riding to the left at
a slower speed, v bike.
Now, I'm interested
in what the car looks
like from the
perspective of the bike.
The bike sees
itself as stationary
and sees the world around
it moving to the right.
To the bike, the
observer on the sidewalk
appears to be moving to the
right with the speed of v bike.
The car was moving to the
right relative to the reference
frame of the observer
standing on the sidewalk.
So to the bike, the
car looks like it's
going even faster to the
right with a total speed
of v car plus v bike.
Let's say, later on the
biker throws an apple
in the direction of her movement
and sees this apple travel
to the left with the
speed of v apple.
Now I want to know
what an observer sees
in the stationary
frame on the sidewalk.
The apple appears to
be traveling a speed v
apple faster than the
biker all to the left.
So the observer on the sidewalk
will see the apple move
to the left with a total
speed of v apple plus v bike.
Now let's say the person
throws the apple forward
at a speed v apple.
What does the car see?
To the car the apple is going
to the left at the speed of v
car minus v apple.
How about the bike?
To the bike, the apple is going
at a speed of v apple plus v
bike to the right.